he knows that his direct confrontational
style rubs a lot of people the wrong way
mean amazing factoids about Jimmy but
you know it's true dan you think about
the way his hero clones it this is where
point guards make their money that's
pretty good
and hero bangs in the three roll the
ball to whirl here he goes in he draws
the whole defense with the idea of
kicking it back knew exactly where hero
was see this is white Duncan Robinson
makes an NBA team you don't do anything
that he's not MGM Park or the park MGM
where we're staying
yeah he was like yeah is pin big ten
network that loves the sounds reactions
here oh he looks like a player does he
play tyler hero with 13 in the second
quarter you note the native language of
belgium belgium ins raid in on the
delivery from hero their sisters number
one all-time leaves for Syracuse women's
basketball very nice Belgians
Oh women very nice I got hurt a little
bit
I will played actually pretty good
without him he was a high volume shooter
he put in by Alexander there
Leslie Robinson here get this thing tied
up yeah instead it's Martin on the
attack laying it in nicely fees for hero
and it's a one-point dinners our
Jefferson off you don't want to get you
don't necessarily have to get the ball
you just can't let your man get a tear
and a throne
outstanding highlight a hero to make
this pretty good here watch you've seen
how many times we see draymond Green do
that right he just lobs it up really
nice pass by hero hero is a very cool